you're doing this beautiful movie and i
was watching the trailer and all i
wanted to do
was pull up a blanket and get in my
cozies
and just nuzzle in to this movie
and you're playing jackie merry
little christmas wedding dealing with
the challenges
of a step family and
this movie also deals with a blended
family issues and so
i'm i'm i was in a movie called blended
and years later i have found myself
now in one as well and we really are a
close family
and spend a lot of time together but you
know
things are changing years go on dynamics
change i
i could use a little of your film's
advice what what
tell me no you know what's funny is
um i remember um reading the script um
and saying i think that this is going to
be like really on time when it comes to
like you said blended families and how
that first
process of even just going through with
the wedding and reading through that in
the script i was like oh my gosh like
jackie has a real battle here you know
what i mean with making sure that
she's not doing too much but she's doing
just enough
to make sure that you know um the
the fiance is like you know comfortable
the kids
are comfortable but she has to be
comfortable and and find her space
in their life and where she fits as well
and so
doing that i just remember thinking to
myself like what what is that feeling
like which to me is always probably
walking on eggshells
because you want to say the right thing
you you're hoping that like
the things that you're suggesting are
the right suggestions and
it's tricky because they're also younger
kids so because they're younger kids
this is
like a new a new transition for them and
you want it to be as seamless as
possible
everything you just said is so
on point and incredibly respectful and
true to like how humans think and feel i
was literally like
i was worried the camera was going to go
to me because i was like
everything you said and even if you have
kids or not i think it's just
sort of a a thing where we're all trying
to figure out as you said the right
thing to do or say or insert yourself or
step back and
it's the dance it's the dance of life
for sure i mean i'm
sure this holiday season i should
actually put like tissue boxes all over
the house
because everything makes me cry right
now i'm so
hormonal and emotional like i was me and
titan had the best conversation
yesterday and in between our
conversation
like i just burst down crying because i
was just like i just
how can i love somebody so much like
then one thought goes to another thought
then the holiday like i got the treat
hold on
i got my tree up over here
oh it's beautiful yeah so
i'm just like i'm in the spirit already
i'm so excited
well kelly i think this movie is going
to be so great
merry little christmas wedding airs
saturday
november 28th at 8 7 central on lifetime
i think this movie is going to be so
great for so many people and
i'm going to be cuddled up watching it
absolutely learning lots of things and
just
enjoying it thank you so much thank you
kelly
[Music]
you